está na hora pessoal está na hora o lado
pessoal de quem fala andar que sejam
muito bem vindos já mais um vídeo e os
estragos e aqui faz na e freios extintor
vocês podem esperar pela minha voz eu
acabei de acordar o eu acordei já vão
jogar com a ge.net freire estou aqui
pelo meu café com támbém forte hoje
vamos agora nos 830 84 eo título nos
comentários meu há muita gente dizer que
não vou conseguir passar 84 eu vou
passar 84 hoje o já sabem pessoal bem
chique e olic gostoso assim já no início
só porque sim só porque eu sou um cara
que eu já sei portanto deixe já isso fui
pra mim foi que aguentar amanhã o espaço
para jogar finais é fredes noite trecho
o google já tu não me perdôo na frança é
uma mulher forte uma boa equipe da sel
branco as emprego e têm força mantém a
joão ganço que sua bunda o samu não
balançou mais de mil ônibus carlos ainda
não ainda não falta um pouco em falta o
voto vencedor ainda tinha um som de
tropical é tropical o noite três pessoal
vamos lá com o saque
meu e 3 disseram que era mais ou menos
fácil agora 84 disseram que é difícil
pra [ __ ] eu não sei até que ponto vai
ser difícil eu acho que nada é mais
difícil do que fascinante 32 e eu
consegui passar o fragmento de crânio
dois portanto vamos lá jogar
op o botão né
agora tem que entrar aqui vamos para o
internacional e possui uma fonte do
jornal daily mail
a loura e na esquerda né atacar o
deputado zé love rock os direitos
funk-se x17 eu não estou lá falar eu não
vi lactte acabei biquíni é que fui tão
calma calma calma está tudo bem agora
conectar o senhor falar e por isso está
aqui ó no a senhora nossa senhora
ae as cabines vai só só vai só vai a
campo só hoje funciona em frente
é isso mesmo agora
agora a oi futuro assim que meu retorno
eu preciso nem por isso não posso ir
agora deixa o uso o que eu preciso para
o café está tudo sujo por onde por onde
por onde o beque
o funcionou sua volta não é pouca fé eu
fiz que é preciso esperar o quadro só
comia estas coisas acontecem
a eles juntam pelo rato já está mais ou
menos possa ainda ventilação já eu tenho
que pôr onde é porque vamos pro foi um
time agora aposentado foxwell o fato e
esmalte é importante a equipe do volume
da ordem
eu não me fazem muito assustadora e
todos os gostos muito foco em riachos
criança o movimento não há luzes e não
sair eu não sei o que vou fazer
ayew off chutá lo dali eu falei eu vi o
sinamm sinan
eu vou tentar mesmo ao meu lado
aqui ganhei porque eu tenho deputados
pelo então né
só quando eu percebi que eu consiga
andar é isso é muito prático embora
fosse você
aqui já estou muito perto da porta
quem vai ver vai conseguir um bom ou um
site ou seja é o esquerdo este é o
estudo da jóia maxilar eu tenho um dom
aquino
presto lord barbano investir em ponta a
equipe paulista o nobel no peru bonin
único bonita aqui olho bonita por seu
canalha de honra e na mão eu disputar um
botão no vôlei ataque roni não
decepcione provolone oea o mexe é isto
então vi um botão no bom nível aaa ano
eles não viam de que era o só consegui
perceber que eu tenho do trombone está a
ouvir a filha da mãe
eu tenho um botão de baixo do laço né
é isso eu tenho um botão de baixo do tai
tai e laço eu acho que tá sempre fugir
não dá pra ver o laço não dá pra ver o
nosso não da lei não dá mais pra baixo
meu não da morte placa loj o botão preto
como tom preto sob os olhares de lula
eu só consegui meu nome o projeto faz
muito barulho a filha da [ __ ] atingiu os
43 do total e eu falei não é no nariz
não é tem que ser o nosso eu mal viu o
show foi o jogo
então por cima isso haja descobri o
leandro biton conseguir haia hora depois
o [ __ ] tv que muito tempo da [ __ ] que
há muito tempo vai romper cubek seguei
só à noite três sintomas têm mais noite
no aeroporto em calma o executou oito no
triunfo que se ouviu foi ouvir miltar
numa sala escura com um barulho do lado
disse que não tem que passar isto outra
vez ela faz 2 a gente com ela não sabe
que o cara com tudo dentro de uma
máscara 1084 possui 3 carol você tribos
e 3 pessoal passei em trecho vamos lá
meu o sentimento de felicidade e mel é
puro este jogo da felicidade
não sei por quê
a equipe fahel a a obrigava legal eu
ensaio está tenda quem tá miles de pizza
meia mas tudo em pequenas é que estou
dentro de alguma coisa que foi da antiga
pizzaria isso que o metrô clínicas já é
suficientemente grande para ter uma
pessoa dentro de tudo o que não explica
como a desculpa não é que eu vou tirar o
pessoal e isso mesmo
olha eu cruzo com a proteína em pó
ainda não sei o que é aquilo livros cada
pessoa é um homem
oslo run for parar isto de sufocação
metade não tem mal pra [ __ ] agora tá
frio o que tem que fazer
o andar tudo andar e oito em obra aqui
isso não é visto não é valor a passar em
frente dela a vai dar susto aqui é que
tem susto em susto para o goleiro bruno
kannan o que só não explica lá no topo
no segundo turno
no fala aí o meu e chuta no abril pro
rock que mistura uma coisa da [ __ ] dj
coisa vocês viram lata porque possui um
bicho do mato tem que manter isso sempre
em cima
parece favor da linha boratto trevis
canalho vai-vai e outro nas 500 milhas
é só fazer isto é só manter isso em cima
ai como collor falou tudo porcina
não sei que tenho que fazer e vai embora
vai embora [ __ ] aí como não eu estou
fazendo tudo certo e hoje um tio filipe
que haja hábito e 30 minutos
o barato já tasso ciro e o [ __ ] é
possível passar esta [ __ ] vamos
alcançar essa [ __ ]
olha ali já barato assumir [ __ ] para
só para o software da pupa conclusivo do
ano já descobriu tenho que agitar a
câmera forró duda se não houve isso tem
que ditar a câmera para eu sair em blu a
água agora sim sair declarou o agora vou
passar isso tudo eu vou passar o estudo
ae [ __ ] x não funcionou eo que não
funcionou mas já percebi já a tupy mais
jovem já tá
meu coração está tranqüilo
vocês tinham razão pessoal é boa é
difícil buscar isto é bom é difícil
já não sinto o dedo já não sinto deixar
um cinto dedo para tudo abaixo canais
bicho-do-mato volta formato jam session
do mato e show barata ficou a dar em
casa com migalhas bolacha que quem manda
sou eu mas só foi canalha inter atenção
aqui este lado da [ __ ] sabe quando você
está num movimento já há muito tempo que
o vosso braço fica tudo fundido estudo
em pessoal estudo em todo coração eu vou
ganhar uma doença cardíaca com steel eu
juro eu vou médicos que irão instruir o
motor oil já faz nascer feliz e acho que
tô com dor no coração agora é o que eu
tenho é o que eu sinto que está em saber
por que o e do ensio que o que aparece
também na banda cai tudo filhos da [ __ ]
vai tomar as murros humor no inferno
murmurou no inferno barata com carrate
agora tem como dar em cima e me liga
toda hora tão farto da aneel tem barata
já que expira em mim já não vê outra lei
já fui
já fui eu fui eu fui eu o farei isso
filha da [ __ ] ecos que ana costa que até
ao saber como é que claro que a
assembléia
a filha do irmão só vão chegar porque
com este vídeo eu não consigo passar a
noite quatro por agora mas eu vou jogar
e tentar conquistar ainda hoje ou seja
vai ser um vídeo então com 84 e cinco se
tudo correr bem eu vou ter que treinar
muito muito para passar esta noite
quatro mil tá muito difícil você ter um
ataque do coração cérebro junto mas as
pessoas para que elas tenham estado já
salva enquanto que o vosso site favorito
e hoje há em princípio vai discutir o
passado 84 já sabem fica idéia é
aproximar